what's going on guys this is Rob and it
occurred to me that we never finished
Annihilation Conquest we covered the
first story where Star-Lord basically
blew up a world but that was basically
it so yes this video is titled the
return of Adam Warlock that's not the
surprising ending the ending of this
story like the ending is absolutely nuts
I'm Gonna Leave You on a cliffhanger
come on guys you should expect it by now
and don't tell me you hate it I know you
love it but here's the thing the basis
behind Annihilation Conquest like we
covered in the first video that we did
with Star-Lord which we'll have a
playlist down in the description so it's
all kind of nice and organized and you
can easily keep up with everything that
that was basically a story that showed
us that the Phalanx this group that kind
of existed out there in Marvel Comics
for years that they're launching their
attack the funny thing about this and
the surprise will get at the end they're
being led by someone and it's really
really cool so the idea behind the
Phalanx is what they do and what kind of
find this out in the next video as well
they're launching an attack and they're
just conquering world after World now
what this does is it initially picks up
with a guy named blastar now this
requires a little bit of explanation
here because in the annihilation event
the one that came before this that what
you had was basically annihilus and his
forces from the Negative Zone which
included blastar invading the main
Marvel Universe and they almost
conquered it right they defeated
Galactus they defeated the Silver Surfer
I mean like basically everybody fell
before them to give you guys some
perspective man and again we'll have
annihilation in the playlist as well to
give you guys some perspective man that
story opens up right like the first page
of the story
is literally Star-Lord Peter Quill
Richard Ryder Nova and a handful of
other people just fleeing for their
[ __ ] lives right just trying to lift
that's all that's literally how this
story opens it's amazing but the thing
about this is that blast star is one of
the few people from the Negative Zone
who remained here after the events of
annihilation concluded and annihilus was
defeated and sent back to his own realm
and so blastar of course like many other
people here these grudges these warring
races who would all normally fight each
other all that goes away in the face of
just this overwhelming force of the
failing showing up and their attack on
holla that's Brazen man right it's like
that movie Red Dawn when like the
Russians and the North Koreans attacked
the United States right just a Brazen
maneuver like damn that's basically what
this is right because to keep in mind
here I'd give a guy's perspective the
cree at one point in Marvel Comics
conquered Earth which has the most
powerful beings in the universe on it
right so when it comes to how powerful
and how capable the cree are they're not
a race to be slept on but the fact that
they're just getting absolutely melted
right just being steamrolled by the
Phalanx this says something man it says
how powerful these guys are and so
that's just kind of the struggle that
goes on here now even blastar himself as
capable as he is this guy falls to the
power of the Phalanx and so what we end
up doing is switching over to Phi
Lavelle now phyllable is a character
that we haven't really talked about in
Marvel but I promise you guys the day
she gets introduced to the MC you man
Sun Sun this girl's an absolute demon
she's currently Quasar she basically
took the role that was taken over by
Wendell Vaughn or at least used by
Wendell Von at one previous point in
time but what she's doing is basically
explaining all of this to Adam Warlock
now we will talk about how we got to
this to this kind of situation but what
she says here is that the Phalanx is a
highly contagious and Hyper aggressive
techno-organic species of unknown
derivation and it's taken over right
weeks ago in a matter of hours the
entire Cree Galaxy became its latest
Conquest now what she also says is as
far as we know all three worlds have
suffered the same fate their populations
are trapped and Enslaved the Phalanx has
infected everything it's invaded all
technology it is everywhere the cree
know they should be afraid they know
they should run or fight back but it's
impossible to resist an enemy that has
invaded you that's what the Phalanx does
it removes everything except obedience
it removes will love bonds of family and
Duty so basically the Phalanx is Reddit
but the the Fey links is numbness the
Phalanx is submission countless Cree
have been put to work as a labor force
to keep Society Running the rest
Millions more are being processed
processing does three things it
identifies those rare individuals with
special talents or powers that can be
recruited to the select the elite
Servants of the Phalanx processing also
studies every captive mind in turn
harvesting data the Phalanx are
systematically searching for something
for what we don't know but they are
hungry for knowledge the third thing
processing does is it disassembles
organisms at a molecular level the
Phalanx you see need a constant supply
of fuel so that's literally it right
like one individuals who are highly
capable they become part of the select
right they're Elite fighting force those
individuals who basically serve no
useful purpose to the Phalanx they're
literally turned into food right but
they also have these what are called
Babel spiers these fires that exist out
there on these different worlds that
actually create this kind of like
enormous Shield barrier which is how the
phalanes are able to keep these
different worlds protected now while
five levels explaining this she's also
accompanied by moon dragon also known as
Heather Douglas now Heather Douglas was
not always a literal Dragon right that
was not always the case instead what's
happened during Annihilation Conquest is
Heather Douglas who is actually the
daughter of Drax the Destroyer she kind
of had this crazy story arc going on
where she was at one point prophesized
to be like the dragon of the Moon and
that kind of a thing in essence it's
like her final form if you want to call
it that right she's kind of been
transmogrified into a literal Dragon
it's one of these things where Dan Abner
who was writing this story was kind of
experimenting with ways to elevate and
change her character because Heather
Doug Douglas had basically been the bald
moon dragon for decades in Marvel Comics
right up until the time this story was
written it was something like 40 years
she basically just looked the same and
been the same so it was the desire to
kind of change things up which was cool
but what this also does is it shows us
that Adam Warlock has been restored now
here's the back side of the story that
isn't necessarily covered here and it's
technically a tie-in but we're not going
to cover the whole thing the idea behind
this is that when the cree Invasion
first started that phylavel and moon
dragon were basically contacted by a
being that they didn't recognize they
didn't know who it was but this person
was talking to them on a telepathic
level and what this person was saying is
you have to go find him you have to go
find the being that's going to basically
solve everything the Savior the only one
who can bring this conflict to an end
you have to find that individual person
we didn't know who he was it wasn't
until we got to the end of the phylavel
story that we found out that it was Adam
Warlock but here's the caveat to this
one the person that was communicating
with philavel was actually the Supreme
intelligence right the leader the the
kind of religious leader and even just
like political leader of the cree but it
was sending out that message to phylavel
because one she would be receptive to it
and two she wouldn't know where to find
this guy but the other caveat here is
that Adam Warlock was woken up too soon
for those of guys who aren't really
familiar with the character of Adam
Warlock and that's fine right I'll
explain it to you guys Adam Warlock is
one of these guys where after any kind
of a major conflict or when he's needed
or something along those lines usually
whenever he sustains like massive
injuries or something he'll go into a
cocoon and he'll basically stay there
right it's Marvel's way of just kind of
writing him out of the Marvel Universe
until they need him again and then hey
this cocoon popped up in this like hotel
room during Infinity Gauntlet and here's
Adam Warlock so uh cool he's part of the
story now and like that said right
that's really how it works but it's one
of those things where he emerges from
his cocoon like a caterpillar emerging
as a butterfly it happens when it's
supposed to happen the reality here year
is philovel snatching up the Cocoon
about a warlock and waking him up she
did it too early which means his mind
isn't necessarily ready for it his
memories aren't necessarily restored and
his power is not at 100 but this is kind
of a crazy theme because as they're
talking philavel is feeding him all this
information and even moon dragon uses
their telepathic abilities to speak
directly to Adam Warlock and even show
him what it is that they've seen the
only thing that Adam Warlock really
recalls is that he says he came to this
place because he was in pain he says yes
now I remember there were Souls
screaming at me screaming in my head
they wouldn't stop there were so many I
started to write their names down I
think there must have been a terrible
War what he's referencing is the
annihilation conflict right the event
that came before this one but before
there's really even any time to explain
the truth about this is he kind of wakes
up he doesn't know who anybody is he
doesn't know who philavel is because in
reality the last time that he was kind
of roaming around Phila Vel wasn't
around he didn't know who she was where
she didn't exist in Marvel Comics at the
time and so the result of that is moon
dragon knows who he is but he doesn't
recognize Moon Dragon one because she
doesn't look the same and two because
his memories are gone and so Adam
Warlock in this situation doesn't trust
anybody he's like I don't trust you I
don't trust anybody else what I need are
answers I need to go to the only person
in this universe that I recognize that I
know the only person that I'm familiar
with at the moment so he literally
snatches up phylaval and moon dragon
intends to take off but in the middle of
that they're attacked by the phalanes
now again this is one of those things
where this is seemingly what the Fate
lengths were looking for or at least a
Target they were hunting for because
Adam Warlock being converted into one of
their select I mean that's a whole host
of power you're talking about a guy who
could go Toe to Toe with Thanos right I
mean Adam Warlock is ridiculously
powerful in Marvel Comics he's more like
whenever you see him he's really more of
like a prophet you don't really see him
fight all that often it's more of him
just kind of being in a leadership
position everybody recognizing how
significant he is and he's kind of like
the Captain America of the universe
right if there is such a thing but it's
one of those things where it's like okay
Adam warlock's here everybody stop let's
listen to him let's see what he has to
say and everybody shuts up right it's
that kind of a situation and so the
reality here is having him as a select
his fighting prowess his access to
Cosmic energies it would be [ __ ] the
capabilities of the Phalanx several
times over right like by an order of
magnitude it would be pretty nuts like
it's it's crazy how powerful they would
become and so as a result seeking Adam
Warlock and snatching him up that's
their goal now the reality here is the
forces of the the Phalanx as they're
here they're being overcome relatively
fast and in fact there is a fight that
breaks out between what's basically
shadowracks a member of the Phalanx and
Adam Warlock and it is a pretty cool
moment right like literally shatter Act
is like will you surrender and Adam
warlock's like and who would I be
surrendering to and this guy's like I am
shatter ax I am select will you
surrender to me or do I have to damage
you first and the response of Adam is
what makes you think you can and like
sends this guy flying
so it's kind of an amazing moment but
the reality here is realizing that
they're overwhelmed and the the forces
of the Phalanx will just keep coming
endlessly Adam Warlock grabs himself by
Lavelle and moon dragon and they
basically teleport out they fly to a
local star and to a base on that star in
order to basically figure out what their
next move is going to be now once they
arrive there right it's the heart of
terma stars what is referred to once
they arrive there it's basically a kind
of secret Enclave where you have a
person that's effectively working on
things right that's working on building
stuff up and evolving people and so on
and so forth hint hint nudge nudge
because when they get there Adam Warlock
is like these people that you see here
these are what are called new Cree he's
like but the new Cree is a project that
has not been productive so far these are
imperfect examples the consequences of
unsuccessful experimentation and so
where philavel asked the question who
has done this this voice seemingly comes
out of nowhere and says so you have come
back to me my son you have returned to
the high evolutionary and the response
of Adam Warlock is yes High evolutionary
I've returned to you now for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with the
relationship between the two there's a
big history between Herbert Windham and
Adam Warlock there's a huge amount of
history there when Herbert Windham when
the high evolutionary refers to Adam
Warlock as his son he's not really
talking about Creator and created that's
not really what he's referring to Adam
Warlock was created by The Enclave right
just a group on Earth that wanted to
conquer the Earth through technological
means right it involved A Fantastic Four
and a few different things so Adam
Warlock ultimately escaped he basically
snatched up Sif from the Asgardian
Mythos tried to marry her Thorin and
Adam Warlock got into a fight because
Thor's like hey that's my girl you can't
be snatching up my girl trying to marry
her that's not cool man she's got me get
out of here you know that kind of a
thing but there can came a point when
Adam Warlock basically ended up visiting
with and really just kind of meeting
with the high evolutionary the reason
for this is because the high
evolutionary had created an alternate
earth called counter Earth that was
literally on the other side of the sun
and the idea behind this is that on that
Earth was basically a guy called man
Beast this was back in the early days of
Adam warlock's stories where he was you
know kind of presented to us as more of
a Jesus like a Messianic kind of
character in Marvel Comics so of course
it was a great big huge fight Adam
Warlock was crucified so on and so forth
but the big thing behind this and the
reason why the relationship between the
two is so significant is because the
Soul Stone as it was given to Adam
Warlock was given to him by the high
evolutionary so that's kind of where
that comes from right that's why their
history is so strong so again it's
really one of those interesting moments
because what you end up doing is
switching back over to the select from
the Phalanx right these forces that had
been sent to capture Adam Warlock and
the reality here is that in their
failure they're forced to confront their
Master the guy who who's running the
Phalanx at the moment right now and I'm
curious to see if any of you guys are
going to guess before I present who this
is here's what I want you to do post a
comment down below and tell me who you
think it is that's running the Phalanx
right before I get to this part tell me
who you think it is honor System right
don't wait for me to reveal it and then
type your comment I know some of you
guys probably would but like honor
System here right who do you think it is
but in these guys meeting with their
Master right like one of the things
that's first established here is that
failure is completely and totally
unacceptable so one of the select are
destroyed as an example to the others
right do not fail me again or I will
keep eradicating each of you and then
quite literally this guy says select
zenmu right this guy's a character
that's been around in Marvel Comics for
a long time it was kind of like a Hulk
type character it's a weird thing it
doesn't really matter but literally it
says select Shadow acts right learn from
Chorus error the Phalanx will not
tolerate failure I will not tolerate
failure I see it is time for me to take
a physical form again I need to deal
with this warlock personally on behalf
of the entire Phalanx for I am the
Phalanx and the Phalanx is my Will Made
flesh and with warlock at my side the
cree Empire will be but the first to
fall to me the person running the
Phalanx is none other than Ultron now
the question that I'm sure you guys are
undoubtedly going to have is Rob how did
Ultron end up taking over the Phalanx
don't worry we will get an answer to
that question and it's really really
cool because honestly it's all the
Avengers fault but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you guys for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace